let's discuss this and other
developments now with our senior
political analyst Maran vashar who joins
us on the newsour let's start Marwan
with with the US actions on the houthis
full round of strikes on the houthis uh
relisting them as a terrorist
organization what do you make of these
us moves and their intended
effect well let's start with the
designation I think uh it is as
dangerous as it's
nonsensical the whole point that America
does designates itself as the guardian
that uh underlines who is and who isn't
a terrorist and defines what is global
terrorism is kind of a a joke for many
people in the Middle East because it's
the same country that
deploys its armadas and aircraft
carriers and military bases throughout
the Middle East and then somehow acts in
self-defense against terrorists and it
is one year after another one decade
another just keep repeating itself be
that as it may it designated the H
terrorist and now this is going to put
the peace process between Yemen and
Saudi Arabia and Jeopardy it's in fact
going to create more retaliation on the
part of the huis leaving them with less
incentives to behave as it were but will
probably escalate both uh the threats to
the navigation in the Red Sea as well as
to the security of the Arabian Peninsula
right the huies of course have said that
they're doing these actions in response
to Israel's attack on on the Gaza Strip
right and and you know looking at the
situation in Gaza today and what's
happening also in the West Bank where
we're seeing increased Israeli raids and
arrests what does it suggest to you as
far as where Israel wants to take this
conflict let's underline what's what
connects all of these right again as we
were just saying earlier about America
attacks Yemen four times
and it calls it
self-defense it's defending the
navigation its own ships right Israel
attacks the Palestinians in Gaza it
attacks them in the West Bank it calls
it self-defense and there is countless
moronic officials and others in the west
and elsewhere in the world that are more
than happy to Parrot some very basic
inaccuracies and falsehoods such as
Israel has the right to defend itself
the Palestinians use uh human shield use
Gaz as a human shield and so on so forth
and just people keep repeating these
things allowing Israel and the United
States to engage in war against the
yemenis and the Palestinians in Gaza and
in the West Bank so it's the same the
United States that backed a war against
Yemen that led to the death of two or
300,000 yemenis is now backing another
war in Palestine that's already leading
to probably 100,000 casualties M tens of
thousands of dead people so these
American backed Wars against Yemen and
against Palestine are connected yeah
connected and yemenis and Palestinians
have a right to you know voice their
solidarity with one another you
mentioned Israel and America and I
wanted to ask you a bit more about that
relationship specifically about the
Biden Netanyahu relationship because
there have been some reports in in Us
Media suggesting that there's growing
frustration uh between the Biden
Administration and the Netanyahu
government with Netanyahu rejected Le
reportedly rejecting this uh this us
plan to get Israel and Arab leaders to
agree on a path forward for Gaza after
the war now the report suggest that the
US is looking past Netanyahu now at a
post is uh Netanyahu
Israel you know what does that say to
you about where where America is right
now is there real frustration within
nyaho government or is this just Li
service the big question is that are we
in the process of repeating what
happened 30 years
ago when Bush father sat in Washington
and told the Shamir government at the
time netanyahu's former boss either you
keep up with our program or we're going
to look Beyond you America looked beyond
Shamir and got Rabin in
1992 I think we having s where we're at
now you think we're having similar uh
because the last three months Biden was
very loyal to Netanyahu and loyal to
their joint operation against Hamas
defeating Hamas that
objective was uh was uh was was the
culmination of that famous or inFAMOUS
hug remember back in October 17 between
Biden nanahu basically Biden was telling
the Israeli Prime Minister I got your
back but once we're done with this
you're going to have to listen
right Netanyahu got the arms got the got
the got the money but he wouldn't take
the advice the advice is actually good
for Israel it's not good for Netanyahu
Netanyahu wants to prolong the war and
wants to occupy and then wants to Annex
the West Bank Biden's ideas are not
conducive to his political future
interesting thank you very much Maran
always good to hear your thoughts Maron
Bashar is our senior political
analyst